In the European Union we succeed with so many things
and it's 2023 and we still haven’t succeeded with
the thing which should be obvious and natural:
gender equality. We are pushing hard for the
next EU health strategy to recognise sexual and
reproductive health rights, that this standard will
be a common standard, from the perspective
of health rights, for all EU citizens.
Mr Biedrón, thanks for being with us. It's already
evening in Brussels. You're just arriving from the
airport. You’re coming from Poland, your home
country. Well, Poland is a country that has been
in the spotlight in the last few years
for the deterioration of women's rights.
This Parliament has been very vocal about it.
It has criticised the de facto ban on abortion,
it has asked the European Union to do something
to change the situation. How far can
the European Union go in that sense?
Thank you for having me. Of course, we see
the deterioration of women's rights in Poland.
In today's Poland women have less
rights than when Poland was entering the European Union
in 2004. So you see there is something going wrong.
And this backlash is not seen only in Poland but
in other member states. What the European Union should do
is to create finally a union of equal rights
for everyone. It shouldn't be a dream, since
we created a standardisation of the roaming
system, of charges. Why should we not create a system
of standard rights for women’s rights?
This is not the case in 2023 in the European Union,
which should lead by example.
But when we talk about reproductive rights and abortion
that falls under national competencies, right?
Some critics say that it would be meddling
in national affairs to try to change something in that regard.
What do you respond to that?
Women's rights are human rights. From this perspective,
should a woman have a choice to decide
about her body or her life?
It's her body, her life, and it should be her choice.
It is not the case in many member states.
When we see the situation where in today's Poland,
because of the judgment of the so-called
constitutional tribunal - which says de facto that
women cannot execute a legal and safe abortion -
because of that, six citizens died,
there is something wrong. We need to improve it.
When we see that among seven million girls and women
who passed the EU border with Ukraine,
the Ukrainian refugees, there are girls raped by
Russian soldiers, and they’re coming to Poland and
they're finding out that in Poland they cannot
terminate this rape. There's something wrong with
the European Union for not giving these rights.
Which tools does the European Union have
to pressure national governments to change that?
We have a charter of fundamental rights, we have
treaties that say that everyone is equal, that
we should have the same standards concerning human rights.
As a committee dealing with women's rights
and gender equality, we are pushing hard for
the next EU health strategy to recognise sexual
and reproductive health rights, that this standard
will be a common standard, from the perspective
of health rights, for all EU citizens.
Another important issue that you're dealing with
this year is violence against women. The European
Commission has put on the table a proposal to create
common rules for all EU countries to deal with it.
Why is it important to have common rules on that?
We are tackling so many crimes, and violence
against women is not recognised by the European Union
as a euro crime. It should be a standard.
There are two important tools which we can use.
The first one is mentioned by you: a special
directive combating violence against women and
domestic violence. We started to work on that.
The second important file, which helps us to
have standards for combating violence against girls and
women, is of course the Istanbul Convention.
Just to explain quickly to people who are watching us:
the Istanbul Convention is the main pan-European
instrument to fight violence against girls and women.
Which should be ratified by all member states.
It’s not the case. And it should be ratified by
the European Union to make one standard for all,
for example, concerning data collection.
I know that Parliament had been asking for the European
Union to be a party in the convention as well...
The Council has just proposed to the
Parliament that it will give the green light to the
ratification of the Istanbul Convention. It is a very much
awaited sign, especially in the context of the
war in Ukraine, where we have millions of girls
and women fleeing from Ukraine, seeking protection
and finding out that there is no one standard
within the European Union concerning the protection of
girls and women against violence.
In practice, what would change by the European Union,
as a whole body, ratifying this convention?
Would this change the fact that six European countries haven’t
ratified the convention yet?
It will bring standardisation concerning protection,
prevention... I mentioned data collection, but it will also have
an impact on the education of girls and women, boys and men.
It will bring standardisation in the help for the victims
of violence. All the tools which will bring
the one approach of the European Union, the common
approach towards fighting violence
against girls and women. It will be complementary
to the proposed directive by the European Commission.
Cyber violence against girls and women
also will be addressed by this directive proposal
by the European Commission. The Istanbul convention is not
mentioning it because it's an older document and
this phenomenon is developing on the Internet.
We, as European Parliament, will make sure that
both of these documents will work together.
And be complementary. When it comes to gender equality
in the workplace, there have been some positive
developments in the European Union in terms of
legislation. This Parliament has just recently
approved new rules that introduce quotas for women
in the top jobs of big companies. Why was it
necessary? Why is it necessary to,
in 2023, introduce quotas for women?
I know. It is surprising to me as well why it's necessary,
but it’s really needed. These kind of tools are helping
women to achieve what for many men, and I say it as
a male politician, we are receiving as that,
just because we are men. In the European Union only a little
bit more than eight percent of CEOs of
of the companies are women. Eight percent!
And women are more than half of society.
There is a glass ceiling which stops women achieving
these high positions in companies. Women are more
educated. 61% of university graduates
in the European Union are women. So what happens
that they are not getting these high profile jobs?
It is, of course, this patriarchal system.
This directive of women on boards is trying to deal with it
by creating the opportunity for women to be represented
in publicly listed companies. I can tell you that
I used to be a mayor. And when I became
a mayor I started to manage municipal companies.
In these municipal companies there were only men,
to my surprise. I asked these men: “Why are there
no women?” And they said: “Women are not interested
in environment cases, in water supply, in cleaning
the streets and so on and so on.
Which is not true, of course. Then I introduced
quotas and suddenly it appeared that there were many
women who wanted to be in these well-paid jobs
jobs and take responsibility for water supply,
for environment issues in the city, and so on and so on.
So just give women the chance and they are very well
prepared to take over.
Another new rule that this Parliament is getting ready
to vote on is the one that we call
the paid transparency, which will require
big companies to disclose the salaries
that they pay to men and women. I understand
that this is intended to reduce the pay gap,
the gender pay gap. Can you explain how this
legislation will be able to do this?
The gender pay gap is a reality. Our mothers,
our grandmothers, our sisters, our female co-workers,
they earn less. Their pensions are smaller than
men’s pensions. This is a reality. The gender pay gap
in European Union is 13%. In some member states
it’s more, in some member states it's less. But it's
a reality and we need to approach this issue.
For us the goal was clear. The more transparency we
have in this field, the more visible inequalities
are and it's easier to approach that. I think
it's is a fair treatment of the workers
that they should know that, while you have the same
level of knowledge and your effort is the same
and your engagement in the work place is the same,
you should be paid equally. And this is not the case.
To conclude,  I’d like to ask you a rather provocative question.
You are a man. You were chairing a committee
dedicated to women's rights. Isn't it a paradox?
I bet you've heard this question many times already.
Yes, I have heard it a lot. And I must say that I’m proud
to be chairing the women's rights and gender equality
committee, because I believe that gender equality
is for men and women. It's not only for women.
We, as men, should be in solidary with girls and women,
we should be supporting girls and women.
There is a special place in hell for men not supportingwomen.
Do we need more education for men on gender equality?
Of course. And it should start with boys,
not only men. It should start from the
early school, with understanding inequalities.
I think we would be all more sensitive if this
was a standard thing. In the European Union we succeed
with so many things and it's 2023 and we still
haven’t succeeded with the thing which should be
obvious and natural: gender equality. We still
treat women like they don't have equal rights.
All statistics show that we still need 60 years
to achieve gender equality in the European Union.
It's a lot. We would think it’s a paradise,
but for many girls and women it's still a hell,
and it shouldn't be.
Thank you very much.
From the European Parliament, I'm Márcia Bizzotto and this is
Robert Biedrón, chair of the Parliament's
committee on gender equality and women's rights.
Thank you very much. It was my honour.